hey Samuel Leeds here and today we're
going to be talking about the power of
personal branding in property so people
know who you are
some thought no better person to bring
on then my good friend and YouTube viral
King mr. David Walsh welcome to the show
buddy thank you very much nice to be
here so want to talk about personal
branding yeah your you know about
property yeah you've done my crash
course oh yeah I'm stuff like that
you're also very much into branding
you've got a quite a popular youtube
show yourself yeah what do you think do
you think that as a property investor
being branded and people knowing who you
are is important and if so why 100
million percent and because if people
know you then ahead of time when you go
into state agents or you call people up
and they already know you you are
already getting over that hurdle of
people getting to know you
yeah so that can save a day that can
save a week that can save a month or a
year worth oh yeah is it really worth
the effort of trying to become
well-known and trying to get branded and
putting yourself out there on YouTube
and all that just to have a very slight
edge that when you go into a state
agents they might happen to know who you
are is it worth the hard work but you're
not going to have a slight edge already
like short term yeah it's gonna be yeah
maybe maybe not so much but long term if
you're if you're looking at your
business which you should be over the
next 5 10 20 40 years yeah if you are
well-known in your marketplace people
are going to be queuing up the people
are gonna come to you to do business
with you yeah not just it's not just a
case when you walk into an estate agent
you'll end up with estate agents calling
you going hey we know what you're
looking for we have it are you
interested
that saves you time money staff all of
those things so I mean I agree with you
obviously because I'm just trying to
think from the vieira maybe they're
thinking really I mean from it was your
idea pretty much for me to have a
youtube channel and you really helped
grow my youtube channel
you came up with the ideas when as
Wednesday when are we missing Windows
although Wednesday because and the
reason for that is because we wanted to
give people an opportunity to be able to
come on my channel exact to brand
themselves yeah I guess he doesn't have
to be that how hard does it have to be
to get branded I mean I
a lot of time doing YouTube videos
running events and it gives me a massive
advantage like when even when I bought
the castle last year yeah
being well-known made that happen yeah
for two reasons reasonable one because
it helped a lot in the auction because
yeah the the actual buyer of the castle
pulled out and you have a lot oh man
well Samuel Leeds was at the auction
let's cook I was in their mind because
they knew who I was yeah and they wanted
me to buy it yeah they wanted me to
bother castle it was of the history and
stuff and there knew that I'd do a good
job because they know me yeah number two
is in raising funds for the castle we
raised funds like that corner abridging
fell through yeah but because I'm
branded yeah because I have a channel
because I'm on BBC News because I can
raise money no problem because people
know that I have a reputation and when
you have a reputation you do not want to
dent that yeah so you you you cannot
just go and mess people around and and
whatever because you're gonna damage
organisation okay so I know that but I
mean what what advice would you give to
someone well before we even get there
what would you say to someone that was
not as out there there would necessarily
as articulate as yeah or myself yeah
I've run it because I'm a Brahmi and
you're an Irish guy but what were you
some people don't like being on video
yeah it's amazing how many people don't
not being on video don't have been on
camera what would you say to them is it
still possible for them to build a brand
absolutely and whether you end up on
video or not is irrespective because
it's how you present yourself to the
public and yeah and that's really what
you're doing you know on a video you're
presenting yourself to the people in the
public which are not in front of them
physically in front of ya you you are
say on a YouTube video stuff like that
like you you're in front of a million
people on your viral video you like it
would take you a good year maybe two to
get in front of a million people
realistically yeah you know so but the
branding has helped with that going back
to the good the question is the branding
is going to what you can do is brand
yourself in a number of ways how you
present yourself the clothes that you
wear how you do business who you deal do
business with we you have a lot of
female entrepreneurs who want to work
with females that's their branding
you have people in the different
religious communities you want to work
help those people or those people want
to work help people who are less
privileged than their yeah that's all
part of good people I see a lot of good
people they're good at what they do
they're good property investors yes or
they're they're good mortgage brokers
yeah but the thing is no one knows who
they are exactly and if no one knows who
you are then you're not gonna make any
money yeah because no one's gonna know
to call you no one's gonna want to do
business with you yeah then she's with
you buy deals from you sell deals to you
known as it you are yeah so I was really
interested I find is when people come
through the crash course and the end up
being you know becoming successful
whether that be through the Academy or
fee across schools or whatever sometimes
if they're really successful they will
want to speak even just for 20 seconds
yeah on my stage chorus they don't the
crash course because they know if
they're if they're if they have a
photograph yeah of them on stage yeah in
front of a thousand people yeah even if
it's ten seconds no one will know that
it was ten seconds because when they put
that on Facebook yeah social media and
people see a picture of them over a
thousand investors yet people think I
can trust them exactly if they had the
authority to be on stage in front of a
thousand people and the powerful people
listened or better listen to them
exactly you know somebody what happens
is and although it might scare the
living daylights out of some people to
go on stage again without me but if you
go on stage for it 1,000 people for ten
seconds your brain is changed forever
done your life is changed forever if you
some of our students are coming on
winners Wednesday yeah winners on the
Wednesday I can't get picked up by that
winners on a Wednesday and and and
there'll be interview yet and we'll
discuss their story which is your idea
yeah why did you come up with the idea
when it's on a well you wanted to be
able to give back to your students yeah
come on the crash course have gone
through your other courses and obviously
been successful yeah you know because
it's one thing where you're telling
people how to do XY is that how to
invest in properties how to get a haitch
ml how to do this it's another thing
when somebody's taken that learning
applied it to their own life to their
own business and come out the other side
successful yeah because if you have a
thousand people tell you the exact same
thing
they say it in a different way yeah one
of those is going to click with you yeah
then they're gonna go yep I need to get
on Samuels course I need to learn what
they've learned and they need to be able
to become financially free just like
that and also it's like a win-win
because not only is the person coming on
the channel being branded well and again
like some of our students they're
successful they're financially free but
their families don't even know or care
yes and their families are just like
yeah you know he's doubling with
property no he's not babbling he's
killing it you know but the family don't
realize yeah but then they come and
witness on a Wednesday and then they'll
send that to their family on Facebook
and then and there would be and their
family will see it we're thinking yeah
jeez like 20,000 views yeah and they'll
watch it and then it will suddenly that
they'll see that person their family
member in a whole new life yeah
Jesus says in the Bible he says that a
prophet has no honor in his hometown
exactly yeah exactly so sometimes these
these successful students of mine then
will being honored in the way that they
do have to be so I want them to be on
winners on a Wednesday to raise their
profile so people respect them better
but secondly the listeners who listen to
the show my awesome youtube fans that
watch the Amazon Wenzhou show now as you
said they'll learn something new
they'll they'll see the breakdown of how
this person became successful so having
different people on doctors nurses
unemployed refugees all these different
people using all these different
strategies yeah they'll be able to teach
some think in a whole new way that I
could never teach so exactly exactly I
think it's a great idea so I mean I'm
just thinking you know someone who's
watching this who's just starting out in
property yeah when do you begin getting
branded like at what point would you
think it would just equate until you
become a multi-millionaire financially
free should you start working on your
brand immediately I mean obviously
having some success helps but where
would you begin to think I need to work
on my brand you need to start thinking
about it straightaway because you want
to know where you are going to position
yourself so they go on your course and
even before they go on your course it's
like who do I want to work what do I
want to do what type of properties do I
want to invest it what charity am I
going to work with yeah those are all
part of your brand and you need to
identify those like for me with my
business if I was trying to work with
everybody who wanted to be on YouTube I
would be
overworked underpaid and would be able
to pay the bills we process that well I
have put my price up but I work with a
specific market yeah I work with authors
experts and business owners who want to
position themselves very clearly in the
market you've got some very very
high-profile clients yes but you've got
a high profile clients and you your
YouTube channel as well yeah pretty big
right you've got lots and lots of you
over a hundred thousand subscribers is
that right yeah yeah so how did you how
did you manage to grow your but how did
you start out with your own personal
blog because I know property is yeah
particularly your you'll know well again
I started out my very first video is
I've got to talk about how to YouTube so
basically how to grow your channel how
to get subscribers how to keep using
your on your YouTube video what right
did you have to teach people how to do
YouTube when it was your first friggin
YouTube video because would that not be
like someone trying to teach property
when they hadn't even done one deal
there's a major difference because the
barrier to entry to learning YouTube and
teaching it is considerably lower than
buying a property and then teaching it
okay okay
so yeah in property yes you can read a
book and yes you can start teaching it
but you don't have any proof behind you
and you need proof you need proof well
you have any proof how to upload a video
it's very quite basic yeah okay so now
you do videos on how to have a viral
video you wouldn't have been able to do
that no cuz they are how to grow a
hundred thousand subscribers yeah
because I never had a hundred thousand
even I had to upload a video yes exactly
exactly yeah and you know when I started
teaching property you know like five
years ago I've been in property for I've
been doing property now for a decade
when I first started teaching it I
hadn't had the level of success that
I've got now yeah I didn't own castle so
I hadn't done big commercial projects
and been able to raise half a million
pounds in a day yeah I hadn't got that
level I was financially free I had hecho
Mo's and see how that side a decent
portfolio but I think the key is if you
are teaching or if you're branding
yourself I don't believe in this fake it
till you make it now since I think be
authentic and be real yes just say this
is where I am if you want to get to here
then I can show you yeah but if you want
to get to here then you go find someone
else to show you and
exactly exactly you know it's like good
yeah like what I use of my tongue when I
got to 10,000 scrubs I could do a video
on how to get your first 10,000
subscribers I don't know a video knowing
how to buy a castle there you go with
off border cap yeah but you know I think
some people get mixed up between
branding themselves and then trying to
claim to be something they're not
yeah you know like it's fake branding I
see in the property space you know
people going on you know trying to teach
how to do a rent to rent or how to do it
and I'm not trying to knock anybody and
I encourage everybody but I mean come on
in order to teach you need to have some
level of success yes you need to have
been doing it for something yeah and
there's so many people like even in the
personal development space who are
trying to teach people how to be
millionaires and how many bunnies are up
together how many coaches are they good
Jillian's you know so many coaches and
and what are they done so I think the
key is you know be authentically I'm
real there's nothing wrong with being a
coach if you're not a millionaire as
long as you're not teaching people how
to be a million yeah you know he's like
hey I can teach you how to get a job
that pays a hundred Rand a year great
because they've done that on so I think
that's really important so I mean talk a
little bit about the benefits yeah
because I want people to really aspire
to be a witness on the Wednesday yeah I
want people to aspire to be that because
I know that when you become winners on a
Wednesday there's a certain level of
you've kind of made it to some extent
yes we'll take people on the show not
necessarily you are definite not
millionaires
we'll take people to show off
financially free people on the show who
are making decent money in reality just
people who are a success yeah they've
got a story to share and if sometimes I
ask people because I have to I have to
have a winner Wednesday every week you
gather yeah
every Wednesday in order to have someone
on the show once a week I need to make
two people financially for it yeah
because 50% of people point-blank
refused to come on the show exactly I
know I think they are frigging idiots
because why would you not come on the
show to talk about your success they're
on camera shy what are you an idiot then
you are stupid what what if you did a
deal or you become actually free to keep
that a secret is so moronic to come and
share on winners whimper and have 10,000
20,000 people yeah I mean knowing what
like what fifty thousand seven thousands
otherwise just
record now fifty thousand subs not super
grateful from the bottom of my heart you
know to everyone that subscribed like I
would never have imagined so thank you
for watching this for being a subscriber
and thanks for your help obviously but I
think it's so stupid because if you
share that you're positioning yourself
as an authority and then people are
gonna be much more likely to treat you
to do business with you to be asked to
speak on stage for two minutes if
whatever a thousand people he's gonna
change your life
yeah to to come on the show like why
would people say no I just don't get
that who knows who knows but you know if
you're interested in growing your
business
obviously that is like yeah the fast
track fast track to become financially
free and then they disappear I'm like I
can't get hold of them now now they're
just financially free they're cool
they've quit their job they just play
golf and trouble them harm and that's I
think if if that's your level of success
if you want to just become financially
free just to then quit your job and go
and disappear and and live in the you
know live in the sunshine and never
contact anyone ever again
like to me that's sad I think I mean you
might well horses for course no I think
become financially free but then become
even more wealthy and more successful
and then show people and teach people
and inspire people and give of your
money and give up your time and be the
best person you can possibly be able to
plan that's what I think yeah absolutely
and I totally agree with you but I can
look at it from the other side is if
they don't do it then that leaves it
open for us to to to to do it for them
yeah but I think you know I'd rather be
on in an army than an island so okay if
someone was asked to be on winners
Wednesday yes let's say someone comes to
my crash course to do some training they
get their self three or four deals and
you have some money yeah and then they
get approached and say hey come and
winners Wednesday yeah what advice would
you give them to give the best interview
they can get I would say just be
themselves okay be them be the best
version of themselves because we have
multiple versions of ourselves we don't
want the slob who sits on the sofa in a
Saturday afternoon
you know just eating crisps and drinking
beer you know you don't want that person
to show you want the person the
professional person to show up with a
personality ya know your personality
comes out in abundance you know we're
not sure the personality there we don't
have to coach you on that you know where
some people are going to be a bit quiet
but once
get talking about something they're
passionate about that's when you'll see
just a metamorphosis yeah of that person
and if if what they're doing is I would
say what's the Y to do what they've done
yeah
find that out because that's where their
passion is weather is their family their
kids whether it is you know their
parents or something like that or just
they want to make a difference in the
world help homeless people are you know
people as fortunate yeah just think of
the white because that emotion and that
passion will come across and that will
get them over any problems they have
been camera-shy because I coaching
people to be on camera is it's a
difficult thing but the what they what
they fail to fur to to realize the why
that they're doing it and if they're why
isn't big enough then they're not going
to be good good on camera simple as
whereas if you can be like I was
I spent four ten fifteen years behind
the camera until I said right I've got
to do this YouTube thing I've got to get
good on camera my first video was
absolutely rubbish the lighting was crap
the video was and that the audio was
probably the best part of us the content
was good I brought I brought the best
knowledge that I had at the time to the
video and then I kept increasing
increasing increasing it then I increase
the quality over time as well for people
who if they are camera shy think of the
people you can affect the people you can
help your family all of those people and
just share the knowledge and your
experience of working with you and the
success they've had working with you to
help other people because they've
probably seen one or two videos on
winners on a Wednesday that has inspired
them let them be the inspiration to
other people yeah that's so true because
you are doing that you work you're
you're giving the gift of yourself yeah
and to try not to hold that back you
actually robbing people of your
inspiration yourself I was just gonna
say it you're selfish for not wanting to
help other people
yeah potentially I mean how many people
got that oh I make it really easy for
people you know ask some nice questions
yeah it's never recorded live so you can
always edit this out yeah if you fluff
up you can rerecord yeah exactly but
really important so just before we kind
of wrap up then so we've established
that it's really
to be branded yes because people know
who you are they're more like yeah trust
people do business with those they know
like and trust ya
and you can build that trust by meeting
lots of people one on one yeah or by
being on camera or on stage and building
it one on many yeah or getting onto a
platform like yours where there's 50
thousands plus subscribers now yeah and
even while you're watching this yeah
yeah there could be a hundred thousand
by the time you're watching this you
have that platform where you can get in
front of those eyeballs and if you are
working in a specific market working
with specific people doing specific
stuff chances are that those people who
are to your target market are watching
the video too yeah that means business
is coming to you and when people come on
Windows Wednesday they get absolutely
bombarded you know core social media
yeah people saying I wanted to venture
with you you know can we do this have
you got if there a deal salsa we have my
deals off you yeah yeah they get
bombarded which is fantastic some of
them even end up in the press you know
we've had people because we have
journalists in our offices yeah and some
of the stories are so good that a
journalist yeah yeah so it's really
quite incredible so what just kind of
wrap up them so what advice would you
give to someone then they're a sold on
the idea they want to be successful they
want to be branded yeah what do they do
now and well if they haven't gone
through your course obviously do that
obviously obviously then as I said
before just pick what you want who you
want to work with the deals that you
want to do and the good that they want
to do as well may baddies your brand
that really is you right because that's
what you do it's like I want to work in
HMOs or into rants and stuff like these
these these are the heirs and I want to
help people with the knowledge that I'm
and the experience I've got that's your
brand yeah you're just gonna boom you
may not want to go out and set up a
training course you may just want to do
the deals take care of your family you
may just want to go on four or five six
holidays a year whatever it is that
that's all part of your brand you see
what you stand for who you want to work
with and who you don't want to work with
are all part of your brand so just sit
down look at that what you want to do
and just start from there and you'll get
more clarity as you work in your
business doing the deals doing more
joint ventures etc etc I love that
thanks so much for coming on but I gotta
catch all you soon
you